hey guys welcome back to another episode
of spectrum for this episode we're so
excited to be partnering up with AARP
that's right
AARP is actually contributing one of the
prompts in this episode where we ask the
parents do you expect your kids to take
care of you in the future this is
something I'm asking I'm actually my mom
about already so we hope this episode
encouraged you guys to start the
dialogue as well that's right make sure
you stick around to the end where we're
gonna share more about AARP but for now
enjoy this episode especially I was
valedictorian of my junior high and my
dad said it's only junior high gaming of
me was like getting in half I am happy
with whatever career my child chooses
three two one go
I'm a bartender and obviously Asian
parents they don't think oh my kid will
be a bartender one day that's why I'll
be happy with whatever she chooses as
long as she's not hurting herself or
others and she has a stable career then
that's fine with me I agree I guess I
disagree because uh I believe he will
make mistakes he'll get jobs that he
doesn't like but I don't think I'll be
happy with whatever he does like if he
becomes a drug dealer or if he just
pursues what he likes without thinking
about that impact on others I think
that's not good enough for me
even if he's happy I believe he has to
pursue something that's right not just
right for him yeah I did tell her after
college you can do whatever you like and
she found a job right away and the
office way nice and nine-to-five after
couple months this is a mom that's not
my life and she just quit the job and
she's a feeling she's happy now so I'm
support her in this she try I think if
my children are not happy and not
successful then I am
failing somewhere as a parent so it's
very important for me to support them
and whatever they want to be in their
lives I want them to be able to like
move forward from a job I don't want
them to be complacent or just like this
is good enough when I know they are
capable of doing more but I think some
people are fine just being here and
that's okay they don't want to look for
that next step I didn't want to go to
college at all but my parents wanted me
to go to college so I went to college I
graduated in theater and journalism I
could have done something with either
one of those but I was like five months
pregnant when I graduated so I didn't
even get time to start my career but
don't you think that if you have a
certain qualification you can always go
back to it if I want to create or
journalism later in life yeah I could
but if I was to work in the field that I
graduated with I would not be happy like
I just already know it and what's what's
the point I'm just living like a robot
doing the same thing over and over again
to make again to make my parents happy I
consider myself a tiger parent three two
one go
now it's growing up I was valedictorian
of my junior high and my dad said it's
only junior high getting a B was like
getting an F you know the Asian okay if
he gets an F yeah that's bad but a B is
not an F and my mom she was always
pushing me to be a doctor so I knew
growing up the one thing I didn't want
to be was I'd never wanted to be a
doctor and I'm going to be more lenient
because I know if I push him too hard
it's going to backfire like that part of
my parents my expectations was for them
to go to college
at a minimum and that's one thing I
always stress at least I would try to
provide tutoring if they needed it I
didn't expect him to come home straight
A's or things like that as long as I
knew they were doing the best that they
could and then I helped them as much as
I could I think I'm a very friendly mom
to my kids maybe because my husband is a
tiger dad and I'm always trying to
balance so one is enough in a house
frankly I'm so surprised to see so many
of you guys here I was expecting most of
you to be here because that's almost a
reputation that Asian parents are tiger
by nature I don't agree with you I'm
Asian very Indian but I'm not there's a
hard to find the balance can be also
about trusting your children they know
what's best for them that's what it's
not sort of pushing them it's sort of
pointing them the right direction the
question is yeah I think them doesn't
mean you have to be a tiger parent you
can do it softly politely they
understand they are sensible but there's
different degrees of Tiger parent you've
heard the extreme I think everyone finds
their own Tiger parent in themselves of
what you think works for your family but
anything doesn't come with an
instruction book
every minute is different and every
child is different yeah I believe it is
sometimes appropriate to use physical
discipline on children 3 2 1 go it's not
the only one on this side well I'll help
you I mean I do believe in hitting my
kids not out of anger not beating them
up but I believe it's appropriate to
teach them discipline now when I was
growing up my dad beat me up with a
broomstick and the stick broke and it
was my fault now that's wrong I don't
agree with that but I believe kids have
to learn fear and discipline in a
controlled environment like that yeah I
think I've spanked my kids a couple
times especially if they put themselves
in danger it's been a long time but I
mean they were very little I think very
temporary because as you raise them they
don't need that you know I mean that
that's shock value they just you know
your words work but on the other hand
when I see why kids that Walmart they
don't care about their parents they're
screaming and yelling and cussing at
their dad like whoa where is the fear I
think 9 times out of 10 when kids get
spanked
it's because we can't think of anything
else to do people say it's not out of
anger but most the time it is out of
anger because you're frustrated they're
not listening
this also love behind it love for them
it's not always frustration while I was
growing up probably half my school would
have been terminated because I used to
get spanked a lot by my teachers so I
think it was more culturally acceptable
at that time and I agree with you I
think it's more about not doing out of
anger you said the same thing too and
also that they couldn't understand why
this is happy
and then you talk to them after that
right yeah actually I used to feel
terribly guilty that I would spank them
and then I would sort of tell them I'm
sorry but that's the reason why you got
spanked so I think it was more of a
teaching learning moment as well I
expect my children to take care of me as
I get older three two one go it depends
upon what you mean by taking care of you
it's not holding your hand
you know if I reflect about you know
what my father expects of me who lives
with us he just wants to talk he just
wants us to be there with him you know
be together and have a meal together
well this is how I define it when you're
old will you be in a senior home center
or will you be living with your son or
daughter when I'm old I think I'll be at
a senior center or a senior home and my
son will support me by visiting and
things like that but he's not going to
be living in the same house with me I
would agree with you somewhat my husband
and I have made a lot of sacrifices for
our children and they're really
appreciative of that and I don't think
we'll need their financial health but
emotional support is very important I
don't want my daughter to think that she
owes me and has to take care of me I do
want to be you know obviously
emotionally be there with her always but
I don't want her to feel like it's a
burden and I don't want that
responsibility to ever be on her because
she didn't ask for it
so I think even just staying in touch
even a phone call it's important that's
taking care of parents I prefer my
children marry someone from the same
culture 3 2 1 go
I think it should be children's choice
who they want to marry and spend the
rest of their lives with I am an Indian
and my daughter-in-law is Chinese and
I'm very happy with my son's decision my
dad told me that I have to marry someone
who's Korean the reason he came was
because of the language barrier and the
cultural barriers but that doesn't exist
for me and my son anymore because I
could speak his language and his culture
perfectly fine so he could marry whoever
he wants I was always told you know
marry Asian marry Chinese my kids can
marry whoever but at the same time I
mean I think for myself would be nice if
they marry someone similar in a sense of
just at least values and things like
that
that's us yeah we are Asian Americans
but our children are more Americans they
don't think like that my ID they've
expressed to me that they would prefer
to marry Asian my children because
they're young at one time they're good
are they younger right oh no no no
they're they're adults and they that's
what they told me but if they choose not
and they change their mind I'm okay with
that too I would be comfortable talking
to my children about dating and sex 3 2
1 go
dating yes sex no not in details at
least I would be embarrassed I don't
think my children would be comfortable
either I wish that they would have
talked to me more about stuff like that
like I found out everything on my own
again I think it's just the whole a lot
of Asian families just don't really talk
about stuff like that they don't really
talk about dating sex feelings that's
why they have sex set in school they
won't listen listen you don't want to
what can we do you have to pass the
course so they have to listen well
that's the thing
I I don't want to learn about that from
school from Hollywood movies or even
their friends I want them to be able to
see my perspective not that they have to
agree with me but I want to be the
primary teacher of those things and not
learn from sex ed from school I would be
proud of my child if they identified as
LGBTQ plus 3 2 1 go
I mean I don't care who she ends up
loving what whatever I'd you know that's
her love that's whatever she wants and
that's fine with me um I remember my son
when he was nine he asked me would you
love me if I was gay and I said yes I
would love you no matter what he goes
I'm not but just trekking and he was
nine years old when I did that and I was
just started laughing and I was like you
know I guess as a parent you don't deal
with it until that comes up kind of
wakes you up a little bit when I was
growing up I mean this the term didn't
even exist I mean there are still
countries in the world that don't talk
about it and don't show it in the movies
and they're actually censored and place
where I grew up it was a taboo yeah it
used to be an Asian stigma that Asians
were not LGBTQ it was like whitey point
stuff now I agree with most of you that
I would love my kids no matter how they
identify us but I believe that LGBTQ is
either unnatural and also the activity
is sinful I'm not gonna force my kids to
believe what I believe I'm not gonna
force them into something that they're
not but I will have concern I'll still
love my kids and I was learn how to
express it but I wish they were not
I believe asian-americans are a model
minority three two one go I always hear
this from my friends who are not Asians
who say you guys do it right you know
you focus on education you focus on
family you focus on making sure that
you're actually connected to your roots
I think when I think of like the term
model minority I think someone that
thinks they're they're the model right
so they're better and I don't think the
way that we were raised doesn't mean
that should be the way for everyone else
you know but we are very hardworking
community all of us and Indians are
scenes and doctors engineers techies and
the highest income an in-group in
America and it does put some pressure on
our children right yeah that's good yeah
has an adult who had really strict
parents like I felt a lot of pressure to
be the model minority especially because
we came here to America because I was
born in Japan I was like I have to be
perfect why did we come here if I'm not
going to be perfect but that little
sense of competition that the back of
your mind is also good makes them grow
higher well my the little voice in the
back of my mind is my parents always
which is like oh be better be better you
know do better
yes so let me ask you a question what if
you parents did not push you to become
better I I suspect you know if I don't
tell my kids to do something and say
okay go and do whatever you need to and
let's say they don't they'll end up in a
bad place in a way I rather hear my kids
complain about me being pushy and point
them the right direction rather than
coming and telling me later in the life
wish you were a little bit strict and
you gave me more direction and you
supported me in a different way right
that's why I think a little bit of
pressure is good but too much pressure
will break anybody and I think Asian
families don't know what the breaking
point is and we're still learning I'm
yeah me as a parent know what
I want to be a grandma but that's not
what my daughter wants right now maybe
but you know that's it's their choices
their life I'm not gonna yeah we're
different generations you're younger
than my daughter
your openness is great you're seeing
things a lot brighter whereas I think
maybe I was more old-school I don't know
it's great I think isn't great no just
we're all trying to figure it out still
young mama thank you so much for
watching the episode of spectrum and we
also want to say thank you to our
sponsors AARP every one of us will
either be a caregiver or need to receive
care from someone maybe even a loved one
caregiving is an inevitable part of life
and often caregivers are unprepared and
sometimes I get cause strains and our
finances you know relationships with our
family and it's super stressful but
luckily we have AARP here to help if
you're not familiar with ARP ARP is one
of the largest nonprofit organizations
that works to improve the lives of those
who are 50 years and older so not only
does it provide resources but it also
provides tools and guides and through
their efforts we hope to increase
awareness and education for the
community particularly the Asian
American and Pacific Islander community
where these kind of issues are not
talked about very often you know one
great first step to start your journey
is to download a RPS free for pair to
care guide provides five simple easy
understand steps to take care of your
loved ones the best way possible yeah
make sure you check them out go to AARP
org slash API go and click on family
caregiving in the main menu and we once
I think he once again to our sponsors
AARP thank you once again for watching
this video for sticking around this long
make sure you like subscribe leave a
comment below and we'll see you next
time
you